So let's look at the problem of multi-core
and many-core power and performance. The problem is this.
We have one core. Let's say it can
spend 100 watts, which is the power budget for
the entire chip. And that power of the
one core is really some sort of a constant
times the voltage squared, times the frequency of the
core. Let's say that we get 100 watts consumption
when we set the voltage and the frequency,
such that we can operate at 3.8 GHz. Now,
let's say that we get two cores. In
that case, each gets half the power budget of
the chip. The per core power in the two core case is one half of the single
cores power, so we need to reduce the
voltage and frequency such that we get one half
of the power. Remember that voltage can be reduced in proportion to frequency.
So the frequency at which we can run a core in a two core system is going to
be cubed root of one half times the frequency at which we can operate a single
core in a single core system, which is
this frequency. And that ends up being 0.8,
approximately times f1 or three gigahertz. So as you can
see, if we now use only one of these cores, we
get to run it at three gigahertz as opposed to 3.8
gigahertz that we could get here. So this is noticeably slower.